[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a fantasy film called
everyday spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
a is a mysterious traveling spirit who
inhabits the bodies of a different
teenager for a single day every day the
movie begins as a wakes up in a high
school boy justin smith's body he takes
a picture of himself as he does with
everybody he's been in and sets a timer
for 11 p.m and 11 50 p.m
rhiannon is justin's girlfriend that
he's ignorant too rhiannon is completely
in love with justin but he neither
replies to her texts nor treats her well
that day a navigates his life as justin
at school and meets rhiannon who
apologizes to him for texting too much
justin tells her that it's all right and
he should have texted her back a total
opposite to his normal personality
rhiannon convinces justin to skip school
with her to spend more time with him the
two sneakily run out of the school the
whole day was magical for both of them
they sing songs in his car walk together
in an aquarium run around the beach
happily and have a lot of fun
as they walk through the park rhiannon
tells him about her dad's manic episode
a few years ago and how it affected her
relationship with him
she feels nice that justin is interested
in her family life
at the end of the day as they're about
to separate a as justin tells rhiannon
that tomorrow won't be like today
rhiannon however ends the day on a
positive note citing that tomorrow is
tomorrow the two kiss and finally
separate a seems to have gotten attached
to rhiannon it's now the next day and a
wakes up as a girl named amy she takes a
picture of herself like always and sets
an alarm to be closer to rhiannon amy
goes to her high school as a new student
meanwhile rihannon is distressed because
of justin's ignorant behavior towards
her again
amy meets rhiannon saying that she's a
transfer student and wants rhiannon to
show her around the tour of the
chemistry lab when justin comes in and
complains about missing practice the
previous day he doesn't seem to remember
anything that happened yesterday which
hurts rhiannon justin even blames her
for him missing practice
amy gets furious and replies to justin
on rhiannon's behalf saying that he's
unappreciative of the only good thing
going on in his life
rhiannon asks her to stop while justin
looks at her weirdly and leaves
after the encounter an upset rhiannon
asks amy to be with her friend alexander
and leaves
cut to the following day
a wakes up as a boy named nathan and
does his usual routine he goes to his
computer and searches for an address on
the map
meanwhile justin and rhiannon are at a
party where he leaves her with the keys
and goes with his friend group rhiannon
is alone and awkward
justin completely neglects rhiannon for
the whole night
she is standing alone when she sees
nathan dancing goofily she can't help
but join him the two are dancing
together when justin approaches them
standing protectively by rhiannon's side
nathan introduces himself as justin's
friend steve's cousin and says that he's
gay
he even suggests being attracted to
justin so he goes back to his friends
nathan then invites rhiannon to go
outside
they talk about rhiannon's type in men
and laugh
they talk for a long time but nathan has
to go before 12.
justin figures that steve has no cousin
they run downstairs and chase nathan
away
the next day a wakes up as a blind boy
and cannot find his phone so he spends
the whole day in his room meanwhile
nathan has become an internet troll
saying that he was possessed by a devil
rhiannon gets a message from a random
number the next day asking her to meet
the person in a public place alone
she goes to the library where she's
approached by a girl named megan
at first megan tells rhiannon that
nathan sent her but then she begins to
explain her life as a moving spirit
she reveals that she wakes up as a
different person every day the day she
went out with justin she was justin then
she was amy and the previous day she was
nathan
rhiannon doesn't believe any of this and
tries to leave but megan begins to
recite the things she said to justin on
their date
rhiannon then assumes that justin and
everyone else is playing a sick prank on
her but megan insists that she's real
freaked out rhiannon leaves the place
the following day she again gets a text
message from a number and goes to meet a
in a diner this time it's an asian boy
waiting for her she quizzes him about
all the things she's done with the
people's bodies he's been in and he
answers all of them correctly he then
introduces himself as a a name he's
given himself
a tells her that he wakes up every day
in a different body which is always near
the last body and around the same age as
him he doesn't know if he has parents or
where he was born he's been changing
bodies ever since he was a kid
he tries to leave as little a trace as
possible after living the day
a then shows her his instagram account
where he posts pictures of everyone he's
woken up as
rhiannon is still a little skeptical but
is beginning to believe him
she tries to investigate the matter
herself and goes to visit nathan at a
church
he claims that he was possessed by the
devil that day and remembers only bits
and pieces of what happened
when he woke up the following day his
phone was logged into the devil
instagram account but he claims that the
credentials were changed before he could
download any pictures
rihanna now fully believes that a wasn't
lying the following day she sees a girl
looking at her in the hallways and
figures that it's a the two talk and she
asks him about nathan it turns out that
a couldn't make it to nathan's house on
time and had to leave his body in a
hurry hence he had forgotten to log off
his instagram on nathan's phone rhiannon
then believes that a had invaded her
privacy by kissing her as justin he
apologizes and says that he doesn't do
that with everyone but it felt different
with her he felt something he's never
felt before when he was with rhiannon
that day for the same reason he told her
about his secret
later that day rhiannon is at justin's
when she asks him what he remembers
about that day but he too claims that
everything is foggy she then asks him
questions about their relationship but
justin is ignorant of the whole
situation
the next day a is a black guy named
george he calls rhiannon to meet him in
a library where he pranks her by acting
like he doesn't know who she is
the two talk about a's life again in the
end the two kiss when george's
overprotective mother comes by and calls
rhiannon a
rhiannon runs away in her car smiling
the whole time the following day a is
beyond surprise to wake up in rihannon's
body she excitedly gets off the bed and
tells herself to be cool about this
while showering a makes sure not to look
at rihannan's body
at school justin approaches rhiannon and
starts to kiss her a is nervous when he
asks rihannon to come over
she blows up at him telling him that he
doesn't understand or appreciate her a
hopes she won't get mad at him tomorrow
for doing that
after school rhiannon goes to her dad's
studio something that real rhiannon
would never do
she bonds with her dad and he even makes
a painting of her
later at night a writes everything that
happened today in a note for rhiannon to
read tomorrow and goes to sleep
rhiannon reads the note the next day and
goes to break up with justin on her own
she has finally realized that he's not
good for her justin is shocked and
wishes her luck before storming away
she then calls a and tells him about the
breakup she claims that she's never felt
more clear about a decision in her life
the scene changes to rhiannon and a as a
different guy driving to her uncle's
cabin in the woods they spend the whole
day together talking and laughing the
two plan to meet again tomorrow but a
has to take the guy back to his place
for the night so he leaves with the
truck they came in the next day rhiannon
waits for him the whole day but a never
shows up
in the end she calls her mother to pick
her up in the cabin her mother is mad at
her for making her drive three hours on
a work day
the following day we see a wake up as a
guy named michael who's supposed to fly
to holland if he goes away he'll be
transferred to somebody from holland and
never come back so he runs away from the
house and calls rhiannon to come to
rescue him
rhiannon drives to him in her sister's
car knocking off the driver's side
mirror to escape from michael's mother
she is mad at a for abandoning her at
the cabin the day before
a explains that he woke up as a girl who
was having a lung transplant yesterday
so he couldn't come he wasn't even
allowed near cell phones so he couldn't
call either
later a takes over the body of a girl
named kelsey who was about to commit
suicide rhiannon meets him at her house
and the two see that she's already
planned out a detailed suicide
kelsey's father would only be home at
five in the morning so if a leaves her
body before that she will probably kill
herself
rhiannon wants a to live in kelsey's
body until her father is home so she can
get help
a isn't really sure if he can do that
but tries anyway it is 11 59 and a is
still in kelsey's body
kelsey's father comes home later and a
tells him that she needs help a and
rhiannon are both happy that they could
save someone's life
the next day a wakes up in rhiannon's
classmate alexander's body during the
day a keeps on boasting about how great
of a guy alexander is rhiannon wants a
to stay in alexander's body for some
time as he did with kelsey's so they can
be together for longer a reluctantly
agrees and lives as alexander for the
next few days
a totally invades alexander's privacy
and declines all of his mother's calls
to enjoy his time with rhiannon
that day was alexander's birthday and
his family had prepared a surprise for
him
he felt bad for ignoring them all day
they too were disappointed in him a
apologizes to alexander's mother and
decides to leave his body after
informing rhiannon tomorrow
the next day a arranges a beautiful
dinner for rhiannon as they talk he
reveals that he won't be alexander from
tomorrow as he doesn't want to take over
his life
he tells her that they cannot
realistically be together forever so he
wants rhiannon to be with alexander
because he is a nice guy and is perfect
for her
realizing that this is their last night
together rhiannon and a dance and talk
and spend their last few hours together
cuddling on alexander's bed
the next morning a wakes up as a rich
black girl katie and drives away in her
nice car
meanwhile rhiannon meets alexander at
school who compliments her smile the two
walk to their call together the movie
ends as we see a post a video on
instagram enjoying his life as a new
person at the central park
because of his unselfishness a decides
to leave rhiannon's life so that she
could live happily with someone else
this is the definition of real love
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching